[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong my name is Mark
Ellis joined by Jacqueline Coley my
incredible co-host we have an amazing
guest the star of always Lola Candace
Cruz is here thank you and this is just
a really exciting it's it's a big big
day for me because this movie I feel
like should have won every Oscar the
year it came out Jack when you're in the
midst of award season this is like your
Prime thing you have the podcast where
you talk about the award stuff going on
what's the latest what was the last
event you were at last night we were at
the governor's Awards which I think if
that sounds important it does this is
where they give out the honorary Oscars
and as much as I was happy to be in the
room with the cast of The Color Purple
as Angela Basset put a Sermon on the
Mount finally you know getting wronged
for the egregiousness that was 1993's
well Love Got to Do With It When she
lost to Holly Hunter when Holly Hunter
should have won for the firm because
that was the better performance in the
year but do I say this is something
that's made my Roman Empire no what was
great for me so you had a good time yeah
what was great for me was that it was
Mel Brooks and it was one of those ones
where I was like I wish I could have
give Mark A plus one because Brooks was
there Mel Brooks was there and I think
John melany hosted just so he could be
up on stage to make Mel Brooks laugh so
that was like a a really a great moment
it's it's been an up and down week for
comedians at award shows but John mainy
credited y'all's side like credited
credit to y'all's side on that one
because y'all needed a win after Sunday
I I so the Golden Gloves were on Sunday
Candace do you watch the awards stuff
like do you get swept up in this you're
you're an actor you're performer do you
get swept up in the award side of things
too I do I love the awards side of
things I first of all I love the Pomp
and Circumstance of it all I think that
that is like America's version of
royalty to some capacity that we have
once a year we get to see everyone get
dressed up there's something about the
Glamour and just I've gotten to go to a
handful of the award shows and be on the
carpets next to to these people and
they're it's just you remember back in
the day where celebrity was celebrity
and you see someone and you just are
just Star Struck there is that energy
that's there yeah whether you're just
like hanging out with your friends or
you're seeing like JLo and the Brie
Larson situation where she like had her
moment and so I think that there's
something about award season that is
just so exciting and just for anyone
that doesn't even R to all the movies
and everything else to see someone work
so hard to get an award and to see that
like relief and just excitement I think
is what I love so much about all of it
look at you making my profession feel
less useless than I do every day oh it's
not at all we bring joy to so many
people I've I've honestly you have just
like reenergized me can you come to my
therapy session please let me know next
time I'll be there every day I'm just
like what do I do I just go drink
champagne and pretend people care you're
in the thick of the playoffs um for your
season and then your football team also
happens to be in the playoffs this
coming weekend as of this recording so
it's it's a big big time for Jack when
Coy right now and I'm just I'm I'm so
tickled pink that you took time out of
your busy schedule to join us here on
Rotten Tomatoes alongside Candace who
has become like our our go-to action
movie correspondent I I hope you're okay
with that title I love that the last one
you were here for was Gerard Butler
Olympus then like later that week
Candace and I were texting each other
and we're like you're watching London's
fall now right it's like so we we kind
of like did our own Trilogy View and so
for this movie which is 13 hours
directed by 13 hours you have to put a
little bit more respect on Michael Ba's
name Michael Bay presents Michael Bay
who has his own Boulevard on the
Paramount Lots Michael Bay direct and
presents 13 hours the secret soldiers of
Benghazi first came out in 2016 and it's
a film that is BAS based on a true story
a harrowing True Story of Survival of
just trying to get through the night of
trying to be uh trying to step up and do
the right thing in the face of adversity
a lot of political Intrigue around this
story but at its core it's about these
soldiers and just them putting their
lives on the line over this the course
of this 13 hour not to be confused with
13 days which is also a political war
Intrigue kind of movie starring Kevin
CER about the Bay of Pigs that's right
which I also did rewatch this past we
just because it's got 13 in it and it's
like you know it's a Bay of Pigs it's
it's Benghazi so I've been doing a lot
of and this is all on the heels of
Netflix had a like like restored footage
in color World War II documentary that
came out right before Christmas oh my
God it's unbelievable the footage is
unbelievable I haven't seen this one say
all that to say I'm a pretty big fan of
this stuff right whether it's you're
you're doing a narrative with a war
movie or it's like an actual documentary
like and I think I'm 43 so I'm getting
to that age where this is just what my
personality is now I just like to sit at
home with a dog and watch war movies or
War documentaries and that's pretty much
all I do with my evenings so this movie
I'm I'm so excited to get y'all's take
on it because I openly gushed about this
movie when it was released in 2016 back
when Christian and I were doing Schmo no
this got the coveted five out of five
Schmo from Mark El which I did not give
out a lot and uh I heard from some fans
that this was their this was their kind
of barometer for any movie that I did
not give five out of fiveo to after this
my like the fans would comment on
YouTube and say like oh well it's not as
good as 13 hours I'm like you can't do
that like it's you know they can though
and this is your Roman Empire this is
like you have to think about this
anytime you love a movie is it as good
as 13 hours that's your threshold right
there and I might be on this island by
myself because it's 51% rotten it is 82%
with the audience score so we'll go
around the room and get everybody's take
before we turn it over to Tim a good
buddy who's going to be telling us what
the critics were saying at the time of
the film's release but I want to give a
huge shout out because on the website of
Rod tomatoes.com right now you can check
out our edit our editors do such great
work we have Michael Bay movies ranked
by Tomato Meter Michael Bay he's a big
name everybody has seen the Transformers
movies on the Tomato Meter not the
highest yeah you know he's got 68% is
his number one movie which is ambulance
from last year or two years ago now so
that's 68% The Rock
from 96 which I think is maybe the best
action movie of the '90s is 67% and then
13 hours is number four but it's still
51% rotten and if you wanted to guess
what Michael Bay's lowest rate on the
Tomato Meter movie is yes it's a
Transformer and it's the last night
deservedly so but how many billions like
do we know how many billions Michael Bay
has Brian looked that up because I would
tell you that tens and tens and tens I
don't think I care about the Tomato
Meter score when you literally have GP
of a small economy worth of box office
receipts and people cace you're you
don't hate the Transformers movies right
you're in on those I love those I mean
granted if we're talking about like
substance of them that's a whole another
conversation but the OG Transformers shy
lauff and Megan Fox like come on
definitely like at least give the first
one it's like award to that everything
else like I agree with the Transformers
last night like that one I didn't even
get all the way through no I couldn't I
I I don't think I used my pass where I
can leave a movie early once a year on
that one but I kind of wanted to once a
year only once a year only once a year
but do you sit through movies that
you're just like I've only used my past
once I I have to sit through this that's
a solemn Hippocratic Oath that I took a
long time ago I have to sit here and get
through this thing so the first couple
Transformers like I love the Camaro
anytime I still see yellow Camaro on the
highway I'm like could be Bumble could
be bumblebee so let's uh let's get into
13 hours jacine do you want to give us a
little no catchup of what this movie is
about I can I definitely can okay I
don't want to give a catch up on what
this movie is about so 13 hours tells
the story of the Benghazi assault in
Libya and basically the idea that there
was an assault happening due to a an a a
Muslim cartoon that sparked violence
supposedly but also there may have been
some civil unrest that was happening
there and this team of soldiers who were
nearby they really weren't even the guys
that were supposed to be on the mission
they get the call and they say you got
to get to Benghazi stuff's about to go
down it's about to get real very Michael
Bay in that and so these group of guys
uh many of whom were just trying to get
home like they were supposed to be
heading back home but they got to do
this one last job and it is literally
one of those covert missions getting
into the country was difficult getting
to the Embassy was difficult and then
also trying to secure the Ambassador and
try to make sure there was this little
zero loss of life this is very much a
Zero Dark 30 but as if everybody knew
that it was happening at the same time
and so we sort of follow this team as
they attempt to you know secure the area
they're they're dealing with people back
in command lying to them they've got the
whole sort of like you know the one
soldier who's like I know what's about
to go down and then of course John
krinski is in it there is a big loss of
life spoiler alert but we sort of follow
them and see who exactly is going to
make it home and who's going to get
saved and this is just an excuse to just
blow up for two and a half hours
John krinski you have Pablo shriber
there you go Pablo shriber and John
krinski fresh off the cover of men's
health John krinsk I might add this is
not the doy Jim from the office I can't
wait to talk about that too because you
because you have like Pablo and you have
like James badge Dale and like these are
kind of guys we've come to know is like
you could you're just good at playing a
tough guy yeah krinski we didn't know he
had this gear so we'll talk about that
once we get into movie talk for right
now Candace you're our esteemed guest um
you have the movie Always Lola that is
now streaming everywh which is so
exciting and it's doing great it's doing
gono numbers on all the platforms um is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong with the
51% attributed on the Tomato Meter can I
do a halfway here I was honestly
thinking about this again this morning
I've been reviewing it I'm like do I
agree with it I would
say they're
wrong but I feel like it needs to be
halfway between the audience score and
the rotten it doesn't need that much
more okay but I do believe that it
needed a little bit more than 51 just on
the storyline and all of the historical
elements of it and what actually
happened because as for Action part keep
it at the 51 solid on the 51 but like
the heart of it like when you got to the
end and I we can obviously dive into
that more but I think slightly more but
not much okay all right so maybe maybe
we're getting into fresh territory with
you maybe we're fresh fresh adjacent
fresh adjacent like
59.9% sure that we go I like that we're
fresh adjacent yes uh jacine how does
one feel about lato meter so this is um
we're in 2024 now and I think I need to
take a different approach to Rotten
Tomatoes as wrongly we've done a few
episodes and I think I want to now say
that Rotten Tomatoes is right in both I
think the audience score is a direct
reflection of what it feels like to
watch this movie because I actually did
watch it at my desk I'm sitting there
typing Awards
predictions and this is playing in the
background and I was like distracted
from like my my job to be like you know
look at John look at this and not a
movie I'd recommend putting on in the
background like when you're doing the
dishes you know what I mean but it was
one of those things where I was like I
was I was finding myself W it's very
watchable it's very audience driven I
would have liked to have seen this with
a crowd but any sort of critical
thinking around everything that is
happening you're like this is a fantasy
like this did not happen this way I know
it didn't happen this way and I know
that this movie is meant to make me
think that it happened this way
and so that gives me the like like 50%
of the people will be fooled by this
movie into being like America and like
the rest of them are be like this is
Ridiculousness like this is not real um
that many white men in that country like
you're a walking red flag like they know
where you are this is like the
suspension of disbelief that we have to
believe that James Bond Could Be an
Effective spy after you weren't fighting
Russians too Gooding to be spy that he
can't be I mean seriously I mean James
Bond now looks like he closes down the
bar every night gambling into the we
hours of the morning he's strikingly
handsome strikingly and has no
compunction about having sex with random
women at of spr that seat all over the
world the idea of that dude not being
anything but a walking STD and a body
bag is just laughable in modern things
like the the you know super uber spy now
looks like Hassan Minaj or like or oh
yes or better yet probably Ramy mallik
because you want somebody with like a
shorter statue that can just like sneak
in you know that that's what I'm saying
so I actually say Rotten Tomatoes is
right in the sense that like how much
fun I had is like an 82% certified fresh
blast but this is ridiculous rot
Tomatoes is wrong this is a hell of an
action movie from start to finish I like
that you got to own it there's a lot of
political uh you you can look at the the
failings around our leadership and and
around the world as far as like how this
situation actually came to pass but if
you're just looking at a setup where you
basically have like a diplomatic you
like you have an embassy and then you
have a CIA anex and those are your two
buildings that we're talking about in
this movie and we are under attack
really at both of them and we have this
small team that is just going to try to
do everything that they can over this
night not only to survive it themselves
but to rescue people that is the movie
then that's the story that we're telling
I thought it did a incredible job of
just being a kick-ass action movie with
a lot of heart that you're talking about
Candace where it's not just the the
whizbang explosions of it it's actually
the heart that you feel underneath it
and what your your rooting for these
guys to pull through so I think that
Rotten Tomatoes got this wrong I think
the audience is correct at 82% I might
even bump it a little higher because
it's just such a well-made action movie
now we turn it over to Tim Ryan so he's
our good buddies our correspondent here
who does all of the review curation
management at Rotten Tomatoes he's great
at it and he is going to tell us what
the critics were saying at the time with
I think I was a critic on Rotten
Tomatoes at this time so what were the
other critics saying about 13 hours back
in 2016 here's two minutes with Tim two
minutes with Tim it might have been
something of a flasho in the red state
blue State divide but 13 hours the
secret soldiers of Benghazi was probably
more discussed and debated than it was
actually seen it had the worst box
office performance for any Michael Bay
film and to be fair there are a number
of factors at play here including the
fact that the movie was not attached to
a franchise and it didn't promise the
kind of bombastic good time that usually
draws people to Michael Bay movies but
it's indisputable that 13 hours fared
far worse with movie goers than the
likes of American Sniper and Lone
Survivor two other gritty War films that
were sizable commercial hits and fared
well with the critics they're both
certified fresh and with the critics 13
hours was genuinely divisive with a
number of reviewers feeling the film
suffered from simplistic politics and
tough to follow action While others
admired both its largely sober tone and
evocative visceral feeling for its
setting 13 hours is rotten at 51% on the
Tomato Meter with 200 25 reviews and it
has an 82% audience score so what did
the critics have to say in a rotten
review Kevin P Sullivan of Entertainment
Weekly wrote Bay works best with chaos
there's no shortage of that here it's
getting from firefight to firefight
that's the problem lending the film a
video game like structure that grows
repetitive in the back half however in a
fresh review will leech of the new
Republic wrote Bay May lack interest in
basic story construction or coherent
battle scenes but the guy has a pratal
skill at evoking sensation the Rotten
Tomatoes critic's consensus reads 13
hours the secret soldiers of Benghazi is
a comparatively mature and restrained
effort from Michael Bay I'll be at one
that can't quite boast the impact its
fact-based story deserves so that's 13
hours the secret soldiers of Benghazi
back to you folks I love that I think it
was it was leech who said uh uh pratal
ability to evoke sensation yeah that's
what you want from Michael Bay and look
I think part of my love of this movie is
sort of a response to the Transformers
movies where I was like where was this
ability in Trans in making me care about
human beings in the Transformers
franchise you know and like all the the
the really intense action scenes where I
was feeling everything in here I just
kind of was like shoving popcorn in my
face and just watching robots fight each
other they didn't really care about for
most of the Transformers movies so maybe
that's it but now it's time to get into
movie talk Brian hit the music we got a
lot to discuss
[Music]
here first and foremost so I saw this in
theaters Jack when you did not definely
C did not but I did rent it this was um
this was definitely I was in enough of a
red State moment that I did rent this
yeah were you back in Texas when this
came out no I was like coming and doing
the back and forth but this was a movie
that honestly I think it may have been
the fact that people kept giving you
crap about it on the
schmoedown that I was like I need to
watch this you want to come defend your
boy that means a lot to me even kidding
you I do think that was part of it like
when I finally saw it was like maybe
2016 late or 2017 early and it was
because this is your like again I I
cannot describe to you how many times I
saw people bring this up in showns in
your comment section this was like a
thing it was my cross the bear because I
was like hey look I I think this is a
great movie and for what it does it's
like you know it's I'm not comparing it
to gret gerwig's Little Women I'm not
I'm not doing that you know it's just
like oh okay this is here that's there
and they're two very different things
what this movie wanted to do I thought
it accomplished it in Spades Candace I I
guess my question to you because I got a
text from you when you were watching it
and it was all caps this is so intense
um when you saw now we kind of except
John krinski is an action star right
because he's great in the Jack Ryan Show
and he's sort of gotten into that world
with like a quiet place and stuff like
that but back in
2016 he was still primarily known as Jim
from the show the office which everybody
loves and rewatches at nauseum I read
that he went from 25% body fat to 8% for
this the RO where he transed himself and
expanded his Horizons did it feel like
that to you watching the movie or
because you're watching this in 2024 now
for the first time you already kind of
expected krinski to just be that badass
I kind of already expected it I want to
say I love John krinski he's one of my
favorite actors because I love romcoms I
love him he's just so endearing and I
think I love him and Emily Blunt like in
real world so much so I always root for
him in everything that he does um but I
was never an office fan I never really
watched it I've seen episodes and things
like that so to me I only have two
versions of John krinski in my head it's
romcom early 2000s an action star that
he is now and I didn't even realize that
this was his first like Venture into the
action world so knowing that watching it
I was like kind of looking for little
bits where I was like oh does he know
how to do this yet like is he good like
watching from the future and looking
back I had to like watch his little
nuances but I thought he was fantastic
it was so weird seeing this movie in
theaters jacquin because first of all
this was coming on the heels it came out
in January of 2016 so you still have
Force awakens just crushing into the box
office and you have some other like big
Christmas Time movies that were still
making a lot of money probably over 13
hours but I'm sitting in the theater and
the two big questions I had at the time
were okay can I can we get back to '90s
action movie Michael Bay can we get back
to Bad Boys The Rock Michael Bay
producer of con a kind of stuff as
opposed to the Transformer stuff which I
was just so tired of and I just felt
like it it it meant nothing to me after
a while so can we get that Michael Bay
back but I think arguably Jack the
bigger question was can John krinski
pull off an action star yeah and this
movie opens and he's on a plane flying
in to this situation and immediately
just the look on his face I'm like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa this this ain't the
the cute schub from the office who's
chased after Pam this is a different
dude and then we're immediately into
this weird situation on a Narrow Street
where we're being interrogated these
guys with guns are coming up to the car
where Kinski and his buddy are and when
he just has the gun ready to go it's
like oh my God this is who is this guy
yeah can I also say too I was
re-watching some of Michael Bay's
interviews about this particular movie
and it's so interesting watching it now
where he was talking about casting John
krinski and he was literally like I was
talking to some of my um colleagues I
can't remember who he was talking to
specifically name dropped in there but
he was like do not not cast movie stars
in this movie you're telling a factual
story you want to do it justice you want
to find guys actually match the criteria
of who these men really were find people
that can do that and you're not watching
a movie star and for me to hear that and
I'm like but John krinski to me is a
movie star yeah so in hindsight that
fact that that was his like break
through to make him into a quote unquote
movie star is just really cool yeah I
look this is where it's like okay I
gotta read between this is where my like
media literacy obsession is like I read
through the bull so like first of all
Michael Bay wanted Mark Wahlberg
originally who was a Bonafide movie star
at that time and I think it would have
changed the movie and it would have
changed the movie but that's where it's
like oh I didn't get what I want so now
I'm going to pretend this is what I
always wanted also two kids this is post
Chris Pratt doing Zero Dark 30 and
Moneyball and they had already shown
that if you take the schlubby actor from
The Comedy and you then give him a
physical Transportation uh
transformation you get a lot of press
around that and so it sort of became
like a bit of a formula a bit of that I
mean more the latest one was K Nani um
when he did the eternals but that has
actually been a pretty standard little
thing that these guys do and it gets the
movie a lot of press you get these men
Health covers just like Chris Pratt did
John krinski got it on this one I think
what's more interesting about John
krinski in this is the role that he's
playing is a very like Stark divide I
mean John krinski is a Boston thesbian
um him doing a role like this I think
sort of marries maybe some of what maybe
the folks back home would want him to be
able to do because like the office is a
great show I'm not trying to pretend
that wasn't like an America oh yeah you
guys see John's new movie he finally got
guns he's finally walking around being
the crap out of people that's what we
like and that is a real thing and I
think this movie sort of got into that I
am more interested in how desperately
this movie movie like American Sniper
they just they wanted to get
conservatives to not hate Hollywood this
was the last Bastion of them trying to
make movies for the red meat state to
say to them this is for you don't hate
us and eight years later everyone is
hoping that half of Hollywood is on a
list I'm just saying I think you would
probably find like Michael Bay and Clint
Eastwood for American Sniper would be
those filmmakers that not even down
political lines just people who like
want just like a a meat and potatoes
action flick would go to you know Clint
Eastwood obviously with his Western you
know Heritage and all that stuff but
Michael Bay too like again this is a guy
who makes the Transformers movies and
they make billions they used to make
billions of dollars right but before
that he was like the guy that you would
tap in the 90s to the bad boys movies
The Rock and it's like this guy just
knows how to tell such a cool story and
have so much just ridiculous action in
it but it's like you like you trying to
do work Jacqueline and then having this
movie on in the background it would
probably be the same thing if you were
trying to do some sort of other task
while bad boys or while the rock is on
and like you just find yourself like I
am going to have to clean the house
later because I got to see how I got to
see if Stanley Goodspeed and Sean
connory get out of this thing a lot yeah
it's an engrossing movie it's a movie
that like pulls you in there's a tension
to this movie I said like two hours of
blowing it up that's actually not what
happens but it is a lot of tension
leading up to could this blow over it
feels like a pot on the on the bubble of
a kettle for pretty much I would say
three4 of this thing and then it really
kicks it in high gear and that kind of
tension over this long of a run time to
really keep that going it is an
accomplishment I don't want to take
anything away from it but this this
movie feels like such a a movie back
from a different time like of what we
would make at that time but also the
types of movies that they would Market
at that time and then two it was like
the way that they did it like they
wanted to get like uh politicians to be
quotes on the cover like like the idea
of that now is just bizarre to me
imagine them sending a movie to Ted Cruz
I guess they did with things like sound
of fre fre but like this is a studio
movie this is not an independent movie
this is part of the like look at the
release date of this movie January 2016
right before I'll just say uh everybody
became much more aware of politics in
this country later on in that year and
so you know Candace as you're watching
this movie for the first time it's
almost an unfair question to ask like
what scene really stood out to because
so much of the movie is it's we're
shooting at each other there's
explosions there stuff going on can you
pinpoint a
where you're like oh that's why I feel
like the audience got it right on their
scale or why this movie is 51% but it's
still accomplish something well I mean I
think the action is probably where a lot
of the audience score comes into play
but my favorite scenes were actually at
the very end right when they're all
sitting on the roof and there's just
like this palpable energy that they did
such a great job of being like something
else is about to happen obviously I know
there's 30 minutes left so something's
obviously going to happen but but
something is about to happen there's an
air of like anytime someone turns around
I'm like oh my God they're going to get
shot something's going to come out and
whatnot and it's the last moments um
that we get the gentleman just kind of
reflecting on their family the fact that
he just found out that his wife is
pregnant like that scene on the roof is
really where I gave the bump in the
score because I think that that's where
the heart of everything is I'm an army
brat myself my entire family is military
so I think when it comes to those types
of things
um that's where they really get me at
the heartstrings is like yes at the end
of the day it is a a big explosion movie
and action and all of that but you boil
it down there is humanity and there's
loss on each end and so for that and for
them to just be sitting there and
talking about it and that being the last
moment that we get with this character
too it was just like oh my God yeah and
and even the the moments that humanized
these these folks for me were early in
the movie where we're just on we're on
the base we're either we're at the
embassy we're at the annex and they're
just kind of sitting around and just
waiting for for something to anything to
happen really I mean I mean these guys
they're working out they're they're kind
of going through their drills and stuff
and then they're watching Anchor Man or
or whatever's on but it's like we still
we know that there might be a situation
you know and now you you also find
yourself going up against your sort of
corporate overlords that you would have
in in in the military system where you
have a chief like you know just just
stand down and now there's no there's
real stuff happening and just to see
them clock the security breach
possibilities at this new location when
they're looking around the building
they're like okay well you're you're
exposed here you're exposed here you
know and and a lot of the the Libyan
forces on the ground were there to
defend Americans and and they did a
heroic job doing that which this movie
doesn't touch on I think enough that
might be something that you know I I
would push back against a little bit
with the filmmaker but if you're
watching that you really feel a sense of
I care about these these folks as people
not just as like them being badass you
know Macho military dudes but you
actually care about their lives and and
that was something I didn't expect
Jacqueline from a guy like Michael Bay
who had just for the last 15 years just
been throwing robots and Mark Wahlberg
drinking Bud Light in our face I think
it's interesting too because this is a
post Jack Bower 24 world as well and I
will say that I think that the the sort
of idea of these lone type soldiers
saving the day you know Lone Survivor
American Sniper Jack Bower they all sort
of have this this was a team of them
sort of doing the same thing a team of
Jack Bowers you know a team of them but
that is actually the part that I have to
be like that's the part where I'm like
there's no way that this is real that's
the part when I'm watching this I'm like
yeah these six guys because it also we
know what the actual loss of life was on
the ground that day and we actually know
that they did not secure the embassy and
that there was actually you know um it
was completely overrun and that there
were hundreds of of sort of folks
attacking it the idea that these guys
were the only line of defense is
laughable like everyone would have died
if that was the case if they didn't have
the Libyan soldiers and that sort of
thing coming about it so that's actually
the part that I'm like this has to be a
video game like just call a Master Chief
and I'll feel better about it than if
you actually try to say that this is
real and I will say post um all of these
things this is based on a book 13 hours
just like American Sniper um they've all
been sort of like poked holes with as
far as like the accuracy and truth and
there's some things that'll never be
determined because somebody on the
ground says this and somebody on the
Ground Zero Dark 30 is another one
somebody on the ground says this
somebody else says that but there's been
enough evidence with a lot of these ones
where it's like they knew they could
sell a lot of media and a lot of books
if they sort of made this idea happen
the one thing I'm more concerned about
is the idea that I was a military person
the idea that the military would give
bad orders is nothing new that is not
something that is whatever and that's
one of the big discrepancies in this
movie is if if you're looking at what
the truth was where you have the the
soldiers who survived said like no we we
got the standown order to not go and we
decided to anyway the chief uh who is
based on a real life person said I never
gave the standown order so that that is
definitely a discrepancy but this is
what's weird about that I know about
chain of command that Chief met have
never gave that order that is absolutely
true but he could absolutely make known
what his wishes were without giving that
order and then somebody down the line
sure gives that order sorry i' lived on
enough military basis to know how that
goes honestly I've lived in Corporate
America long enough to know how that
goes but yeah no that is the part where
I'm like you got to read between the
lines a little bit it is the human story
it is the the act the act that they sort
of humanize these guys the fact that you
know look guys that have families back
home and they're not bad on the eyes
like all of these things sort of like
play and tug with our heartstrings
because a certain point you're looking
at which one of these guys is going to
make it right you know yeah you and and
that's part of the thing I mean this was
also around the time when I started uh
getting to do Uso tours and like going
to the Middle East and like just being
on bases and stuff in various parts some
which are you know you always feel very
safe they always do a great job making
you feel like you know I'm not in the
newscaster helicopter situation but
you're over there and like you know you
know that these guy and and you're
relaxed that you're they're you're
entertaining them at a comedy show but
you know at any time something could
could happen where it's like now that
switch gets flipped and so to see the
way that I think Michael B is a guy that
I trust intrinsically to show me what
it's like when that switch gets flipped
where it's like we're just sitting
around doing nothing we're bored out of
our mind we're watching comedies that
make us feel like we're home and then
boom here now now we got to go into
battle and it's like it just it's it's
almost like you're so well trained that
you're not even thinking consciously
about it it's now it's time to do the
cool gun loading thing and make all the
noise and just run into whatever
firefight you have I think this movie
does such an exceptional job of showing
The Bravery of people like that so I'm
willing to issue some of the this might
have that way this one may have been for
the portrayal of that cuz I think that
that's deserved and Michael B said that
that was his goal he was making like he
wanted to make uh the veterans who he
said a lot of them worked on a lot of
his movie sets and people in like the
grip and sort of um behind the scenes
and below the line guys he wanted to
give them a movie and I think that's
what this movie does he turn he turns
those guys into the Avengers which is
great um does not makes it about as
realistic but I get like the earnestness
of wanting to do that let's also
remember every movie with um American uh
military portrayed in any way is going
to be somewhat positive just based on
the fact that the US military does that
and they these guys maybe criticizing
the apparatus of the US military but in
the end the guys are still Heroes which
makes this a recruitment tool so you
mentioned you mentioned the Avengers and
one of the you know benefits of being an
Avenger is that you have your own very
unique costume and you can tell who is
who and everybody looks different uh
Candace did you have trouble kind of
differentiating cuz other than now the
super famous John krinski it's like
these guy like Pablo shriber for
instance was in den of Thieves and which
are with our boy Gerard Butler and and
he's great in it and I loved watching
him that even more because I'd already
seen 13 hours but like everybody else in
this movie it maybe by Design just kind
of Blends in and feels interchangeable
even though they are based on real human
beings with their own stories yeah I can
I just say obviously I hope whoever is
listening this is not a spoiler but um
one of the gentlemen that does die I had
to literally check and I was like which
one
died like I hate saying that but they
all looked the exact same except for two
of them and that of I had three of them
I had Tonto I knew who he was he was
very identifiable and he was like the
the comedic like relief in a lot of the
movie they all have that same sort of
like sense of humor where they're going
to be very sarcastic as they're like
shooting people but Pablo that's Tanto
who play tto he was like the funny one
he was the funny one where he was like I
he would always come in with the on
liners
and for a second I thought he was the
one that went down CU they don't show
the face of who's fallen and I was like
no he just said that he was protected
and now he's not um yeah they'll say
something like Bravo's down and I'm like
wait which one was Bravo yeah so um
those were the two that I could identify
outside of that I had no idea who was
who they didn't do a really good job of
us like letting us know whose name was
who either identifiable it's like this
guy's redhead with this red beard this
guy's the brunette guy with this beard
never really say their names so I could
identify who uh David Denman was because
he was also in the office he was also in
the office he was also in the office and
like no offense he also looked like the
guy that was on his first movie Set like
he was the guy that did not look
comfortable compared to the other yeah
he did not look comfortable in any
aspect of this portrayal I could tell
that like James Dale Badgley Pablo
shriber and some of these other Bale he
feels like a dude who just walked out of
of like a real boot camp and just and
decided to lend his talents to a movie
exactly um and so the other reason why I
know Pablo shriber because um I follow
his Instagram which ladies um you should
he's a fan of Surfing he's a fan of
Surfing and thus you're a fan of his and
when he's done surfing he often takes
Instagrams and I'm awesome everyone
should check out Halo it's going to come
back does he wash his Surfboard on his
abs is that how he washes himself oh I'm
not kidding you like he gets out of the
sea waterer and then he like puts the
puts the wet suit halfway down I'm
putting way too much sorry will he be
James gun's Aquaman um he's a very good
actor he was also an American Gods but
he's fantastic but I will go ahead and
say his his Instagram is also great and
then John trzinski so those three were
identifiable to me but no I couldn't
tell you who Oz was um or TIG do we like
Michael Bay I still one of the big
failures of two years ago now was I
still haven't seen amb
with Micha B directed with Jake gyen
Hall who might be you know another guy
where it's like you knew him as this
incredible actor sort of Oscar Contender
and he seems to now be able to transform
more into whatever he wants I mean he's
a he's a chameleon but I could see him
being like a krinsky like badass if he
so chose maybe that is him an ambulance
and I just haven't investigated it yet I
really want to see ambulance I watch
house too okay he and and he's Joon
Hall's going to be in Road House he is
the next guy yeah he is the dude but he
already kind of did that with Jarhead he
kind of did that with like some other
movies so he's been that guy but they've
always been so like hurt lockery they've
been like yeah he's going to play an
action star well actually he did it with
Prince of Persia that's when he wants to
let people forget but you
know he did do that did see I did see
Prince of Persia and he was I can't even
say he was good because it's like so
miscast but it's like yeah he did the
job on set and it was fine but I feel
like Roadhouse is going to be the movie
that announced to the world that we have
a guy yeah because you know we're
talking about krinski making this
transition and Jack when you made a
great point where like in the 80s when I
was a little kid you had like your van
dams and stallon who were just guys who
seemed like they were just carved out of
granite from birth right and they were
just she's jacked action stars and then
after Die Hard you started getting like
a more normal dude just like in whatever
situation you know you had like Bruce
Will is just trying to get out of a
building your counter re's just trying
to stop a bus from exploding and now you
have like let's take schlubby actor it's
almost like an experiment that Hollywood
likes to do let's take a guy who's known
for comedy or known for just kind of
being a little doughy like a Chris Pratt
and let's make them into Star-Lord and
Guardians of the Galaxy and you're right
it it's such a career not even change
for them it's just a career Boom for
them like I remember seeing a video of
John krinski and Chris Pratt together
and they were doing the murf which is
this thing it was named for a guy um
this legendary Soldier passed away and
that was his workout you do think it's
100 situps uh 100 pull-ups 200 sit-ups
and 300 push-ups or something like that
then you like run a mile um and it it's
I've done it it's very very hard it's
very very I I did not feel as as well as
those guys looked in the video
afterwards but they were doing it
together so I'm just kind of watching
these two it's like oh okay this is this
is kind of the the crowning moment of
their transition and now they can be
action Stars I think it's kind of cool
that we do that though I think it's cool
that we do that I think what's
interesting before is those guys were
just assumed to have good bodies cuz
there's definitely the like Chris
Hemsworth in Star Trek is not the Chris
Hemsworth of Thor right Liam Hemsworth
in even the first Hunger Games is not
the Liam Hemsworth towards the last
Hunger gam so like it was just assumed
that these like nice is body guys not
subby but like nice-ish body guys they
could like turn it up it's now the like
spectrum of like we will literally take
an actor who looks like he never lifted
anything y um and only eats donuts and
who was strictly known for for basically
standup way Kum was you know exactly
also can I go ahead and say and I again
I'm friends with his wife who was also
on the podcast so I'm not saying
anything it's so weird the backlash he
got the white boys get fit all the time
never get any backlash he decides to get
fit and they're literally like who are
you like that's like really like in
retrospect like yeah I never understood
it I just saw the you know before and
after and I was like dear God I wanted
to be like's dad and order the socks of
because C's dad ordered like socks made
of his son being jacked and I'm like I
kind of want those socks too like it's
it just looked it was my favorite thing
about eternals absolutely and like the
idea that people would um be upset about
that like I'm like what is going on like
he got in shape I think for you as a
comedian too cuz like what hope do you
have Mark if they're going to like rail
against you for getting in shape well
that's the thing like you know again now
we're recording this in early January
and it's just one of those New Year's
resolutions
Lo you're about to to try to break your
bench press record your squat record you
have that thought in the back of your
head like what am I doing this for again
like I have two sets tonight I'm not I'm
not going to get drafted I'm not I'm not
going in the NBA lottery like what am I
doing this for you could be the
next prevent Alzheimer's that's
literally my main reason for working out
I hate it I hate every aspect of it oh
see I love working out you do the okay
so your workout is like this intense
boxing kind of thing that you like doing
too I do boxing and then I also work out
at uh campaign training and do like
heavy lifting and things like that now I
do so I've got some I've got some good
numbers cice has kindly offered for me
to take one of her boxing classes with
her and and I'm like I I I need to like
do another Boxing class for like a month
before I step up enter the cruise Dojo I
will only say I only started doing
boxing because majority of the time I go
out for movies they or any type of
audition it's they want me to be like
the badass the the the can I say
I can cuss on this yeah yeah the
the the whatever and so I was like
I don't have anger in my life I'm a very
happy positive person and so I was like
I need to get more anger in my life so
that's why I chose these workouts and
now I'm just obsessed with them so I
feel very relatable to John krinski in
this regard I was the nerd and now I'm
like you know what I'm just going to
like try and be the superhero I'm going
to see you in a movie I'm going to be
there front row opening night I'm going
be like I can't wait see Candace she's
so good in romcoms and she was so good
in that that Coming of Age movie Always
Lola I can't wait to oh my God look at
her we share a birthday too so I mean
John krinski and I were one and the same
here you said birthday C October 20th is
was this John krinski pre poost Emily
Blunt did these abs get him Emily Blunt
was post cuz he talks about he had just
had the first baby oh yeah yeah this is
first baby movie I I do like that for
nice little thing for an actor to tap
into as well playing this role like I
have something to live for back home
that is that is a good one I also knew
that's when he was going to survive also
I knew John krinski was going to survive
because he was top billing but um when
the minute that baby popped up I was
like yeah he's making it back cuz they
need that like moment at the end uh but
I love that for those women it's like
you loved me at my nais like Rob
Thomas's wife you know like met him when
he was like his heaviest and then it's
like when he gets skinny it's like yes
we still love you um yeah I definitely
um are they our favorite celebrity
couple right now krinsky and Emily Blunt
or is there another celebrity couple
another C I really do love Sterling K
Brown and his wife Michelle they are
like the black Emily Blunt and John
krinski but Emily Blunt and John krinski
are pretty far up there I was at the oh
God here we go so after make sure you
check out Jack's Awards podcast thank
you the awards tour podcast but I was at
the universal party post Oppenheimer
after the Golden Globes and I got there
early because you know I didn't go to
the show because whatever I didn't want
to sit through that but at the end of it
I'm there and and John krinski is's just
there waiting for his wife and I think
that is just like kind of adorable he's
just like sitting there talking to um
Jack Quaid who was also not in the room
I just kind of like that because that's
not every Hollywood couple did you ask
krinski about paish rber did you say hey
no I should you connect me with this guy
I would ask John krinski about so many
other things I would ask him about how
many times he's made how many times he's
watched The Devil's wear's Prada knowing
that he has Emily like literally
Emily
yourin you get both you know but like
literally that is to me I have so many
like random people that I thirst over he
Rand he thirsted over her in that movie
and then he bagged her like that that's
manifestation speaking of 2024
manifestation here there you go
celebrity couples it's make iten alexio
hollerin and Serena Williams like he
knew he had no shot like he may be a
billionaire now he was not he was just a
dirty little boy with a website going up
to the greatest tennis player of all
time and being like I'm a holler and she
was like why okay I think overall this
is just a whole podcast about the Nerds
succeeding just fight for the Nerds and
the ones that just come to the top yeah
fight for the Nerds and let the Nerds
get shredded if they so choose so choose
ex because it doesn't get much nerdier
than like a krinski or an anani
initially from where they came from and
now they're shredded we all appreciate
them for you know being Inspirations and
I'm not saying I have their posters on
every wall in my house but just a couple
right just a couple just to remind me
inspirational what I'm training for
which I do get confused about
sometimes Alzheimer's I'm telling you
that's the best reason to exercis
there's got to be more to why you're
wake you wake up at like 6:00 in the
morning to go to these Works workouts
legitimately Alzheimer's and endorphins
they make you happy they like yeah a
little a little a little bit of dopamine
a little bit of dopamine but weed is
legal in California so I've got plenty
on tap uh I was
just this is great oh my God right this
is the kind of serious action movie
podcast I was hoping for about you
serious I've been pushing for for this
movie on the show since we started the
show and I was like at some point we got
to talk 13 hours right and like it
producy Lucy and Brian they're like yeah
we'll get there eventually and Jack was
just looking at me like you poor thing
you poor poor thing all right yes is
legal in our state I I honestly kind of
forgot what I was going to say cuz I
just wanted to laugh at that so go so
then I will put a button on this by
saying the reason I work out Mark likes
his beers at the end of the night so if
I'm just thinking a couple Coors Lights
that's what's going to get me through
these squats um we I do want to go to
mailbags we got a good question in here
Brian so let's hit the
[Music]
music you can email us anytime let us
know what movies you want us to be
covering what you thought about the
movies we did Cover what do you have to
say about 13 hours and how it relates to
weed being legal in California you can
hit us up RT is wrong rotten
tomatoes.com you can be like Nicholas
Bayfield who's a ketchup crew member and
a very fresh one at that Nicholas writes
hi Mark and Jacqueline as you've already
discussed Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
in one of your earliest episodes I think
now might be the time to follow up with
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny at
70% on Rotten Tomatoes Tomato Meter it
ranks lower than Crystal Skull 77%
certified fresh score which is slightly
disappointing and despite a fresh change
in the filmmaking team I think dial of
Destiny is more on par with Crystal
Skull than the original trilogy
particularly with the use of CGI and
older Harrison Ford and suspending your
disbelief on particular scenes like the
third act thanks for reading thank you
for the suggestion Nicholas I kind of
like that idea I didn't really get a
read on whether Nicholas liked the movie
or not so we'll have to get a little
deeper into that um keeping it close to
your CHF Sir Nicholas yeah I'm a
defender of this movie am I flipin loved
this movie I was so ET and I saw it with
the worst audience ever again this is
where I hate you sound like The Simpsons
Comic Book Guy worst audience ever I did
but I saw it at the can film festival
with all of these French people that
were like this is not a movie this is
just CGI and they it started at a 40 it
started at a 40 when it debuted but I
Flippin loved this movie I felt so bad
that the reviews uh early didn't reflect
that and I think that depressed his box
office phbe Waller bridge is amazing I I
I look uh the Last Crusade is what is my
favorite Indiana Jones movie sorry
purist but I love it so sorry I'm I'm
that's my favorite Indie as well are you
an indie fan uh Candace not I know oh I
I feel like you going to come from me
I've only seen one and it's just the one
that I uh with sha buff cuz I was
somehow on the set for that so that's
the only reason why I watched anybody
listening or watching right now has
instant forgiven you because you're not
talking about the Beloved classic
Trilogy that's like a and kingom of the
Crystal Skull I can defend it to a point
yeah I would suggest the original
trilogy because it's just fantastic and
it's if nothing else it's Apex Harrison
so I'm going to put that on my list put
it on the list you're our action movie
correspondent so you I got to come back
in dip your toe in the adventure Waters
and if anybody has a problem with the
third Act of dial of Destiny need I
remind you again the third Act of Last
Crusade is the most insane thing I've
ever seen in my life there's an immortal
Soldier he's 800 years old ja kicking it
in the back are you serious come on and
all of those booby traps none of them
messed up in all of that amount of time
they still work pretty crazy stuff uh
Candace thank you so much for joining us
today course it was a pleasure seeing
you again having you here um thank you
for checking out 13 hours the very
intense Thrill Ride that it was um where
can everybody like check out what you're
doing what you're working on and always
Lola where is like the Hub where where's
the easiest way to find it I guess oh
thank you thank you guys for having me
on I love that we went from your Roman
Empire and all of this down to what we
talked about um so it it's such a blast
but everyone can find me on all my
social media at Candace R Cruz across
the board um hopefully some exciting
things down the pipeline in the New Year
in 2024 and then with always Lola you
can find us on Apple and Amazon that is
so cool to say isn't it it is I'm sorry
I'm just like oh my God this is so cool
it's and it's real we got to get you on
Voodoo we got to get you on Voodoo and
you are fantastic in it as well I know
it had a great Festival run and now
everybody out there can I see always
Lola so put the com in there if you're
searching for it just in case always
always comma LOL there you go um
Jacqueline where can folks check out the
award show podcast yeah the awards tour
podcast you can find on Rotten Tomatoes
in the awards tour Hub we have the
podcast link also you can go to our
Rotten Tomatoes movie clips channel to
see the video version and anywhere you
listen to podcast Spotify Apple um I
don't know where the other places that
people listen to podcast at um but you
can find it there as well wherever you
put the candy in your ears that's where
you can find the awards tour podcast the
awards tour podcast and our last episode
is with Sterling K Brown he talks a
little DC about maybe or not him playing
a little character called John Stewart
we get that going uh we also have our
first episode is with lwi Goron there
goener all right so check that out see
they're doing big things I'm just here
anchoring this show as best I can
defending a great action movie like 13
hours my name is Mark Ellis at Mark
Ellis live I have upcoming tour date
starting in early March we got Vegas
Boston Chicago Houston New York uh some
other Portland some other places so uh
you can check that out at Mark ellis.
live and uh once again email us RT is
wrong at rot tomatoes.com subscribe rate
and review all the stuff that jacqulyn
was encouraging you to do for the award
store podcast you can start here and do
it for here for us as well um in a
couple weeks jacine we got a brand new
episode dropping what are we talking
about we're talking about a movie that I
feel is also unfair mign this is going
to be me a little bit to you because I
felt like the canary and the coal mine
talking about the greatness that is the
kingsman and nobody else like the king's
man the Kings man not the kingsman
circle with the the third one the third
one with the very fine Harris Dickerson
I couldn't remember if it was actually a
movie that got made or not it is oh God
I'm I didn't throw shade at it I just I
had never seen it before I was in the
dark and maybe I've been shown the light
I I do feel sometimes with these like
comedy white boy action movies they all
get kind of lumped together and this was
one that should have been differentiated
it really should have been all right so
I I think you just got Candace to tune
in on that episode she's uh in I've
already got a couple things I need to
listen to when I get in the car after
this I'm like I want to
hear I have movies to watch come back
and tell you all the feedback she used
to just be our Gerard Butler uh you know
representative and now Candace Cruz we
moved on to John krinski if we're
kicking ass it's Candace Cruz make it a
tagine make that's our bumper stick you
can get it at our merch store when we
have one uh for producer Brian for
Candace for Jacqueline I am Markel the
whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes and
rotten tomatoes.com thanks for tuning in
to Rotten Tomatoes is wrong and we will
see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
time